[Music]
hey what's up guys it's marquez back
with another video for mkbhd you know
what that is back there you know what
that is going that's my samsung galaxy
nexus no i'm just kidding it's actually
just right here
all right well today we're going to be
taking a look at the top accessories and
top things to have once you get a galaxy
nexus i know not everyone has one but if
you've seen my videos on it you'll know
i love it and i've decided to actually
deck out my galaxy nexus with
accessories so today i'm gonna be
showing you what you guys should have on
yours and if you watch this entire video
you're in for a special treat including
a special guest so the first thing you
get when you get a new phone is cases
now i mentioned in my unboxing that i
typically carry my phone naked but uh
there are some great options out there
for cases sgp makes this really nice
case it's called the ultra capsule and
it's really flexible material that makes
it really easy to install on your phone
and take off your phone it's just one of
those cases that you can just throw on
and take off anytime you want you can
get a bunch of different colors you can
just grab a couple and throw them in
your car and have them on the go and uh
they're really really nice accessory for
your phone another case i really like
for the nexus is called the incipio
double cover is called the double cover
because
well there are two parts to it you can
install the soft part of it on your
phone and that's kind of the same as the
sgp and it'll basically cover the back
part of your phone and protect it from a
little bit of soft and you know it's a
little bit of shock resistant but when
you put on the second back part then
you're really adding the protection
layer so that's a hard case and that'll
add a whole second layer of protection
so you're paying for a little bit extra
here with the incipio double cover but i
do recommend it if you want a little bit
of extra protection for your phone again
it doesn't cover the front of your phone
but it's definitely good for the back
but if you really want to carry your
phone naked if you don't like cases at
all you don't like the bulk there are
screen protectors and this is what sgp
is really good at they make screen
protectors for all kinds of devices like
your ipad your galaxy note whatever you
have they have a wet install screen
protector and a dry install the wet
install is is basically you spray it and
you get it on your phone and i'm proud
of my near perfect installs of screen
protectors and this one was actually
really easy as you can see here i got a
near perfect install and it's called the
flex and just stays on your phone the
dry install which is called the ultra
oleophobic actually has this oil
resistant coating so it's actually a
little bit slicker on your phone than
the regular glass would be so that's a
nice bonus and you don't have to wet
your hands or anything you can just
literally peel it off and slap it on
your phone and once it's lined up you're
good to go now notice a couple of you
guys in the comments were telling me
that your galaxy nexus has less than
desirable battery life so without any
further ado let's take a look at lamar
and his suggestions this is wilson tech
1 with a look at the extended battery
for the galaxy nexus hey mkbhd audience
you ready to get charged up oh sorry he
kind of told me to tone it down a little
bit for this video sorry about that
let's take a look at sgp's cool f60q
mobile charger okay so the cool f60q is
an amazing battery pack for any of your
android phones so guys this thing is
6000 mah and kind of put in perspective
the galaxy nexus battery that's 1850 mah
so this can definitely power your galaxy
nexus at least three times maybe a
little bit more and so the cool thing
about this get it cool because it's the
name of okay anyway so this is not
limited to just your galaxy nexus if you
open this little slot here you can see a
switch and when it's on switch number
two is any android phone and we switch
it over to switch one it is the iphone
now i've tested this with the ipad and
for some reason i guess this doesn't
have the power output it is not able to
charge the ipad have not tested it on
any type of android tablet but i assumed
it to be similar for that so it looks
like this is just for phones all right
really quick example right here pop this
in you notice there's no indicator going
on i'm going to click that you just see
the phone pop up in just a moment and
there you are and now the phone is
charging nice indicator lights here to
let you know how much battery is left i
like that a lot although it looks heavy
it actually is pretty light and you can
easily fit in your pocket or your purse
like me i mean the pocket part not the
not the purse i promise now guys if you
think this is going to be a cheap value
you are wrong yes this thing is 124
the only way i can imagine this is if
you're going to be on the road cut off
from society or cut off from any kind of
power if you're hiking or maybe people
who are at ces this week i can only see
them using this where you didn't have to
worry about power for a few days because
otherwise for everyday user i can't see
why you would spend 124 so it is
definitely a niche product for a niche
audience to do specific things and if
you fit that then test it out so there
you have it this is the cool f60q
battery pack on wilson tech one and now
back to mkbhd so there you go guys
that's basically it that is what we got
for our top accessories for the samsung
galaxy nexus again make sure you like
this video just
if you like it leave a comment below
what else would you recommend uh do you
carry your phone naked for the longest
time i did but i i'm starting to really
like the uh the cases i've been using so
either way let me guys know and uh talk
to you guys in the next video
peace
[Music]
[Music]
here they actually have two choices here
a dry install and a wet install it's
actually this way dry and dry they
actually have two choices a dry
they have a sweat install screen
protector